okay let's go Oh ladies gentlemen
welcome to a very special episode
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentle walk up to the 50th
episode 50 episodes and I'm here with
that I can't believe that I've done 50
episodes and I want to thank everybody
for watching and listening and
subscribing and doing all that stuff you
know what I mean
this is a special episode for y'all I
know her by letter woo-woos Here I am
I'm doing a solo episode episode number
50/50 episode ja and I just want to
thank everybody but even before I start
let's see let me look at the calendar
and let's see where we gonna be as of
this particular episode of the podcast
all right so when that comes out all
right I'm gonna be way am I gonna be
where am I gonna be um Brad Garrett I'm
gonna be in Vegas so if you in Vegas
everybody I'm gonna be at the MGM Grand
and Brad Garrett's comedy club that's
gonna be from October 7th through the
14th so no 7th to the 12th I think it is
or the 6th to the 12 whatever it's on
the website it's on my website then a
week after that you know I'll be in a LA
area at the rec room at Huntington Beach
and I'll be at the La Jolla comedy store
coming to San Diego the 18 19th and 20th
so that's good and then I'm actually
gonna do some dates with Dane Cook you
know can you remember when he was on my
podcast he was I gonna have you on the
tour so I got a couple dates a day in
the 24th and 25th not sure where those
are but everything will be on the
website anyways this is Riven with
Griffith 50 episodes if y'all been with
me from the beginning and you know I
used to do a lot of solo episodes in my
living room I didn't have even have a
set up you never mean but not that my
setup is all that great but you know it
is what it is and so
excuse me here we are doing briefing
we're afraid but anyways I want to just
start by I got some I got some some
weird new music well I got some weird
music for somebody wait I want to get
his name right this is great
well it's got Steve Solomon - Solomon
sent me a couple of tracks they're not
even really tracks they're just like
little jingles but I think it's kind of
cool so I just wanted to play them for
you guys right now here's one so I was a
kids show and they need to sit this
other word - this one's kind of cool
[Music]
and
[Music]
Steve Solomon thanks bro
that's uh you know first new music I've
gotten in a while I also got some stuff
in the peel box
episode 50 I want to talk about I don't
have the shirt cuz my girlfriend stole
it ex-girlfriend well she probably might
be my girlfriend by now again but
anyways it says hey Eric I'm a huge fan
I love the podcast and Griffin gaming
you are the most upbeat happy people I
know so I decided to ship you some merch
it's from my tiny super local company I
print the shirts mainly from for my
friends and family hoping to spread some
positivity and call it it's stay happy
apparel that's the name of it stay happy
apparel bye Andy Andy I don't have the
shirt somebody took it from me but I
know it's my ex but anyway you know what
I thank you for the message in the notes
and thank you for sending me the shirt
it's actually a great shirt it's called
stay happy apparel it's got a little
company so maybe that's gonna blow up
once again - I gotta light my candles
from the hangover candle company
hangover candle the guy always hits me
up on Instagram because I still I don't
even need new candles yet bro because
these haven't burned out yet but I'll do
thank you for the candles and these are
dope you know the candles the smells
good it keeps a good nice ambiance now
here's a little special card I got guys
it says not everyone can do what you do
right and it says please start an air
Griffin album fund the people need your
album disappoint person wants to be this
thing and check this out sent me a
hundred dollars to start my album fund I
mean I don't even know what to say and
it was a really nice personal note from
Val I don't want to really want to read
it you know but it's just a lot of
really nice message in this letter it's
a personal letter and I just I just
really appreciate this kind of love
right here so maybe I will work on a
rhythm with Griffin Christmas album so
if y'all got some Christmas tracks out
there let's put out a riff from a
Griffin Christmas album you know what I
mean let's do that but Val thank you
very very very very very much for that
okay and now so got I was on Rick
Glassman's podcast take your shoes off
and he brought out some like some booty
wipes right he brings out some booty
wipes because we haven't found making
jokes about it it's really hilarious
Rick laughs minced podcast is really
funny take your shoes off he's an
interesting cat so maybe his podcast is
growing so make sure you tune into that
one but then next thing you know I go to
my peel box and I got a big-ass box from
a place called booty wipes headquarters
booty wipes headquarters y'all so they
sent me booty wipes I got a little pin I
don't know where you would ever wear
that but you know what let's put that
there
let's put that there for booty wipes
it's just a big-ass box big-ass box like
this of like I think it's like portable
little one oh yeah little one stop
little one stop booty wipes I'm talking
about you guys don't even see how big
this box is is it go big-ass box oh I
got a lifetime supply of keeping my
booty nice and clean so my booty gonna
be clean for a long time y'all hello
hello okay so anyways anyways my booties
gonna be clean for a long time y'all
thank you - booty wipes for sending me a
huge box of booty wipes I don't you know
it's individual packages though I wish
it was like look you know so you could
take one now I gotta have all this like
maybe there's other stuff in the box you
know what let me look and see it looks
like it's all the same yeah it's just a
big box of booty wipes so you know what
I might send a box out with uh you know
you send me something everybody just
sends me a good ass jingle for if you
make Christmas music from me i'ma send
you a box of booty wipes one little box
of booty wipes so anyways thanks to
booty vibes but anyways here we are
episode 50 solo episode lot of stuff
going on in the world that I wanted to
get yep about I got some questions I got
some questions from the fans that I'll
go over before the episode ends I got
some great stuff from on Instagram
Instagram and Twitter from people so
I'll try to answer all those questions
and just talk about what's going on with
me and all this like you know this last
50 episodes it's just you know it's been
really great I've had some great people
on Dane Cook Tiffany Haddish tone Bell I
mean the list goes on and on Tony rock
Rick Glassman Adam Ray
Jeremiah Watkins I've had so many great
people a lot of my really good friends
have come on and I still got some more
people to go I'm gonna get Chris D'Elia
on do all these guys but you know
they're just so busy doing their own
thing shooting movies and stuff like
that but you know it's really exciting
times to be doing a podcast you know I
know you sometimes it feels like it's
oversaturated but it's not because you
know the YouTube is huge
the the listening market is is huge us
there's so many there's so much time in
the day that when people want to listen
to podcast you can you know you you're
at work so I appreciate you truck
drivers I appreciate you people at the
office right now listening just you know
trying to help the day go by and I
appreciate you helping me I'm using me
to help you get your day by and just two
people that just randomly like to listen
to podcast or people that are just fans
I mean it's really great and I enjoy
doing it and I'm gonna keep doing it
until like you know I can't do it
anymore or maybe I'm just too busy
because I was filming a movie in Boston
I film I was in this Netflix movie they
already announced - so I could talk
about is called the sleepover on Netflix
this kind of action comedy family movie
it was great but I was only on set for
like four or five days and I was in
Boston for like a month
so that [ __ ] was crazy but I had some
crazy on the set there was this dog in
in the movie right so in the movie I
play like a WITSEC agent I play like a
witness protection program agent for
like so the premise of the movie is the
mom is in witness protection her kids
and family don't know and then you know
she gets found out and then so I go so
there's a scene where I go to the house
just because I think something's wrong
and then the kids they think I'm a bad
guy and they attack me right and then
they tie me up
so now in the movie I'm tied up and then
there's later their dog is in front of
me and this dog man is supposed to like
sit there and growl at me man they
couldn't get this [ __ ] dog to do
anything that they wanted it to do and
so I'm starting to be like I'm kidding
uncomfortable cuz I'm tied up you know I
mean they got me tied up at Christmas
lights and other stuff and in the mood
not just for the movie but in real life
I have to be tied up so it looks good so
I'm uncomfortable this dog ain't doing
what it's supposed to do and I'm talking
about like it's supposed to be a trained
dog and I know it's an animal it's an
animal but I feel like a coyote with
rabies that we found on the side of the
street would have done just as good as
this dog this trained dog supposedly
trained dog so if it was crazy I even
asked a producer about it and I was like
yo man what's up with this dog and he
was like I know you know cuz this is
what happens so when you film outside of
California and I say you film like in a
place like Boston you have to hire local
hires that's why you get a tax break to
film you know your stuff in another
state like a place like Boston so we're
filming in Boston and then Boston is
gonna be like alright Massachusetts is
gonna give their production a tax break
but you have to hire local people so I
don't know if you know like more power I
mean I don't want to like trash the lady
completely but like this particular dog
that they chose just was not doing what
it was supposed to do and it just was
like a nightmare like just there was two
dogs it's supposed to be one dog you
know it's like the two dogs are being
one dog you know in the movie but these
two dogs didn't look alike at all one of
them was considerably bigger than the
other one totally different
personalities I just don't know how it's
gonna come across so there's a little
insight for that movie when you watch it
and I asked the producer like yeah bro
what's going on with this dog and he's
like oh yeah and I was like I was like
he was I was the best trainer in Boston
that was the dog that was the number-one
dog and I'll say well what was he was
like number two had Lyme disease that's
how bad the situation is so if you got
in Boston and you a dog trainer get into
the movie business I'm talking about
anybody in Boston if you're in Boston
and you do makeup hair you should look
into getting into the movie business
because a lot of productions are moving
they're doing a lot of TV shows there
and according to like hair and makeup
people there not enough hair and makeup
artists in the Boston area to cover all
the productions so you know it's
something if you want to get into that
industry should really look into that so
but look out for that movie coming out
to sleep over it was weird I spent all
my per diem money look I mean this is
like first world problems but they had
me in a really fancy hotel at my my
hotel bill was so high I mean I gave all
the per diem money and I still had to
pay like $100 it was crazy but and I had
a good time but the movie the movie
should be fun so make sure you look for
that on Netflix coming out probably next
year or something like that who knows
maybe people won't even remember this
podcast episode by then all right
one of the other things I wanted to talk
about is like I'm a huge Big Brother fan
and so they just had this season 21 a
Big Brother and the other night they had
the season finale and the season's
finale was ruined because there was
allegations of racism against the guy
that won but like right before he's
about to win they come up with these
allegations and listen the guy is not he
was kind of a [ __ ] throughout the
season Mickey whatever his name is
Jackson you know he was kind of a
[ __ ] but to me it was just part of
Big Brother to me it was all games so
like in the first few episodes of the
season okay if anybody if you don't know
Big Brother okay big brother is a is a
social experiment people live in a house
it's taped 24 hours a day and the whole
point of it is there's competitions that
the people compete against each other in
a scheme and connive against each other
to vote each other out until there's one
person left and that one person gets
$500,000 I just want you to understand
the motivation behind Big Brother is to
win $500,000 this ain't a [ __ ]
popularity contest this ain't some sort
of like oh let's see who's the best
character no this is people lying
scheming being people that they're not
not you know just being them actually
the most awful version of themselves
often times they're not to win $500,000
okay let's just put that out there all
right so they had this thing called bebe
campout okay they had a camp direct
all right so like they had to it was
like all these people just got into the
house and then they all had to nominate
a camp director and then that camp
director gets to pick four people that
are gonna get kicked out of the house
basically right so he raises his hand
and he's for other people raised their
hand
one of them's cliff who was the oldest
guy on the cast like really old for Big
Brother in my opinion but we'll get to
that then it was like a black dude and
isn't always not a lot of black people
on Big Brother it's a black dude this
fat Latino girl she's fat okay I'm just
gonna you know she's a big girl Jessica
a big girl her and it just happened to
be like it happened to be like the some
of the minorities in the group raised
their hand to to be nominated for this
position the white guy won so in he's
saying it to the camera his logic is
okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put
up two people who also raised their hand
because they seem like a threat if
they're willing to be this then you know
they're not necessarily gonna be allies
for him so they're strong people let me
get them out cut cut to ninety nine days
later and they're and then people are
claiming that that was a read it solely
based off race and age and I just the
guy was a [ __ ] but I got no sense of
racism from him watching the season now
I didn't watch the feeds cuz you can
watch the 24-hour feat if you're real
junkie you could watch the 24-hour fees
and I didn't [ __ ] watch the 24-hour
fees because that's like too much you
know and they even have a show called
Big Brother after dark so you could be
watching that and but I love the show I
think it's a horrible train wreck social
experiment that accentuates the worst
attributes of people's personalities for
money for them to win five hundred
thousand and for us to look at home
would be like wow these people are awful
here's what's wrong with Big Brother
right now okay first of all they this
this push towards diversity let's make
it diverse and so for them diversity
doesn't just mean race they want to do
diverse in age and size big brother is a
like
more than half of the competitions are
physical competitions like endurance
competitions and running around and
jumping off [ __ ] and if they had this
old guy who to his credit he lasted all
the way to the final four but I watched
a whole season it to me cliff got more
lucky than anything else they were just
bigger targets and they had this fat
girl who every single physical
competition
she failed okay she failed and they even
made the show itself made fun of her she
was like this like hold on to some [ __ ]
competition she had to hold on and they
cut to her and she's like I just want to
prove to everything you hear the
voiceover I just want to prove to
everybody that girls my size and then
she falls they did that on the [ __ ]
show okay
I don't have any I'm not fat shaming I'm
not a this ain't about age this is about
this particular show if you're gonna
have a fat girl on the show then you
need to alter the competitions where she
has a chance to win every single one
that's just my opinion I think that
whoever the weakest link on the show is
physically like if you like have
somebody with a wheelchair in a
wheelchair on Big Brother but then you
make sure all the competitions are
strictly mental or they're like you have
to use your upper body so it seems like
this person has a chance if not you are
setting them up for failure and that's
exactly what happened and at the same
time you're also positioning them to be
victims and that [ __ ] pisses me off let
me tell you who should be on Big Brother
it should be all pretty people like just
get hot just super hot people with in
shape physiques and then let them battle
it out and we at home watch these pretty
people be awful okay cuz that's what the
[ __ ] is show is it's people being awful
alright they lie to each other they
scheme they make promises that they
break they break their word it's just
you know they make these alliances and
then they break them they get into these
romance
says that you know people fight against
each other when you combine pretty in
shape people a Thai personality model
looking women and he's you know you know
straight big big tough straight guys and
even like the gay dudes who go in there
who are like super athletic if you're
gonna have these people in there and
then you're gonna combine them with like
unathletic you know fat out of shape
people and I'm not even talking about
even with personality if you're gonna
bring these people who are like like
they've been bullied outside you know
they're not the prettiest person you're
setting those people up to be victims
and I just think that it's ridiculous
okay you watch TV to escape Big Brother
it's like when you watch love island
when you watch in love Island or some
dating show and it's like all about
pretty people having sex that's why
we're watching I don't need that [ __ ]
diversified with people who look like me
okay you know [ __ ] don't want
to see me on love Island with some
pretty chick in a you know in a bikini
not on TV you don't want to see that cuz
you could be like what does that do
doing you know it just sets it up for
bad vibes and that's what Big Brother is
doing in their attempt to appease all
the the social justice warrior [ __ ] out
there who are like we need to diversify
everything no not everything this show
like this girl Nicole Nicole who
finished third she didn't do much all
season they wanna claim that I was her
game to Lilian or the radar but she's
one of these types it's like you know
she's not a outgoing person you know
she's not ugly by any means but you know
she's not like you know the the soccer
star chick who has this beautiful body
so she's already gonna be set up as like
the underdog they they put her in the
house you're the underdog and let's see
if she can get all the way but the
problem is they set this whole thing up
of like okay they had like they were
having a meeting use their having an
alliance meeting and somebody wants to
trust to come in and they're like hey
we're having a meeting and then they
turn that into bullying they made that
into bullying no no you know what if it
was a hot person trying to come into the
room
the Alliance wasn't with they would have
just said done the exact same thing but
because you set up the victimhood
because you set up where like here's our
victims our people you know the the
underdogs of society the fad the old the
Nerds let's put them in with all these
pretty people then you instantly create
this thing with the people at home are
like I want that person to win take that
element out just make Big Brother what
it is awful pretty people trying to win
$500,000 period or if you're gonna
diversify it completely diversify it and
dumb down the competitions let's make
let's make the competition's like like
the old guy cliff he won this one
competition where he had to hold a board
you know and like like balance a ball I
was like perfect competition cuz it
didn't have to do with him running a
marathon or holding on to anything cuz
every single one of those competition
the fat girl and the old guy they fell
first
every time the final competition was you
had to like there's like you had to like
go across some swings that are held up
by rope cat chick Jessica wasn't gonna
be able to do that that would have been
a [ __ ] disaster this she had to jump
over some stuff like why set people like
that up for failure you know and then
then you're gonna make it look like oh
we made this competition so the straight
white athletic male she's gonna be the
one that's gonna win this that's how big
brother is so when you add people like
that in your attempt to diversify [ __ ]
all you're doing is set them up for
failure and making everybody hate the
8'i personalities which were supposed to
hate them anyway because it's Big
Brother they're doing all this [ __ ] for
money so now there's this whole thing
and I thought the finale was ruined
right before they're about to announce
who wins they go oh by the way dude
there's allegations that you were being
racist ninety nine days ago the dude was
blown away
it was so inappropriate so inappropriate
and then you know he won and he just had
this stoic look on his face like wow
y'all just called me a racist in front
of America Emma
family and by the way the people that
called him there were the [ __ ]
that got kicked off early cuz y'all suck
at big brother that's why you got kicked
off you're not good at it and by the way
let me say this not being good at big
brother is not an insult it's a
compliment
cuz this like this girl Kimmy who's a
beautiful black girl she sucks at big
brother okay
I'm sorry you suck at big brother and
I'm glad you suck a big brother because
you didn't want to lie and scheme and
act a certain way that's what it takes
to make it all the way in that stupid
show so to have this dumbass show this
stupid horrible social experiment and
then you want to like then you want to
so you want to have a stupid stupid
social experiment where people where it
accentuates the worst attributes of
people's personality and then you want
to blame them for it and then you want
to criticize them for what it does it
was so [ __ ] stupid but that's the
culture we live in right now alright
that's my big brother rant let's go to
the singer mic on a fifty episode
what else has been going on recently um
the Chappelle special came out man and
people were fired up man
you know and I used to be the kind of
person that was like you know this is
like people are too sensitive you know
people are too sensitive and I realized
you know what it's okay that people are
sensitive you know what it's I'm fine
that you're sensitive I just don't
appreciate how we're going about dealing
with the sensitivity you know it
shouldn't be like you know these people
were out there don't watch the special
cuz you know it's like hey you don't
watch it [ __ ] you know what I don't
need you to watch it critic just go you
start to watch it and you don't like it
don't even write about it cuz no one
cares you know what I mean the need for
critics is gone the neat you know but
they're just there as a sounding board
for the super-sensitive types you know
but like you could just decide for
yourself now you can look and see that
over a hundred thousand people loved it
and these seven to eight critics you
know like a certain percentage of them
didn't and it's like so the the people
on my side were like making a big deal
out of that but my thing is like so what
that's those people's job like whatever
no one really cares they have to justify
their position so if they want to be
like oh this was the worst thing ever
fine cuz the rest of us saw and were
like oh I loved it look if listen jokes
are jokes all right you have to
understand the setting that you're in
you know he put out a comedy special
he's a social commentary type of comic
but he's also very like you know he
could be he's out there you know what I
mean he his thinking isn't it's not
regular people thinking there is you
know there's satire there's like and he
was you know he was really digging in on
some of these topics to make you think
and make you laugh if you didn't like it
if you took things too personal I
appreciate that you felt that way and
but you should also be like you know
what it still was also for entertainment
I'm sure he didn't necessarily mean to
take offense like understand the nuance
of what the guy was talking about but
there was so much backlash and it's like
this position is like who gives a [ __ ] I
just made 20 million dollars to do this
so he's in the position where it doesn't
matter and so then a week later bill
bird special comes out paper tiger funny
it was very funny but the first four or
five minutes definitely it was in that
same tone of like getting on the social
you know the the social justice warriors
getting on the sensitive types and so I
saw this one article they got well the
guy was like you know if you don't watch
you know if you if you if you cut out
the first five minutes and you'll enjoy
cuz the rest of it is different and I
looked at and I was like you don't
actually understood what the guy who'd
meant because the fur yeah the first
five minutes he was in that vein of like
you know [ __ ] social justice warriors
and he Twitter you Twitter mongrels and
all that stuff and then it was a
different special after that I was more
personal and vulnerable but I think the
first part was just as important but
bill bird didn't get the same kind of
backlash that Chapelle got and I think
that it's because Chappelle's special
was like it was like if a natural
disaster hits one of these little
countries you know and there's like you
know just just devastation and then what
do we do is we get all riled up you know
and we like do a telethon and we're like
everybody's donating money in the whole
country cares and then a week later
there's a similar natural disaster but
now we're like oh I already did all that
so I'm kind of I don't have it in me to
do it again that's what Bill burr
special was it was like oh another heavy
hitter comic hit you with some funny
social commentary and now you don't have
any more energy to [ __ ] and complain
like little [ __ ] because you you blew
your load when Chappelle's came out now
we need another one to come out and
another one and so we can just level the
playing field so you just be like oh I
don't have enough energy to hate every
single special that comes out so
hopefully another big one will come out
you know of one of these like you know
heavy hitter guys and just have you know
it's just comedy man it's just comedy
and speaking of like I'm on my podcast
now and so it's like I gotta be careful
now you we have to be careful or
thoughtful or whatever the word is about
what we say even on here because these
[ __ ] are gonna go
and take some [ __ ] out of context and it
might hold it against you not to say
that the Shane McGillis the SNL guy who
he got on SNL and then he got kicked off
because they found some racist and stuff
on his podcast
I heard the clip you know I'm not a fan
of it you know what I mean
I'm not a fan of that type of comedy
anyway like smug white guy comedy that's
not my thing I have my own smug brand of
comedy you know but like when I heard it
I was like it's like I get it I'm a
comic I get what he was trying to do but
it's like you put it out publicly and
our people who are gonna be like I don't
like this but to say that that's who the
guy is
and just to kick the kicked a guy off
the show was uh I don't know how I feel
about it I'm actually kind of 50/50 on
it cuz you have to way is it enough
backlash where people are gonna be I
don't want to watch that show or there's
so much negative talk about it that
you're just kind of like yeah let's just
cut ties with this guy and move forward
I don't know
cuz then all this other stuff started
coming out about him and I don't know if
it's true or not but it was just enough
things where I think SNL was like yeah
it's just let's move on from this guy
kind of like the Patriots did with
Antonio Brown it's kind of just like
this isn't the the risk/reward is not
good enough and I think that's what
happened with that guy but I don't know
I think it's again I don't know how to
feel about it because like I'm not a fan
of the guy but I did see this one really
stupid tweet like really stupid yes you
know this girl and she's like you know
I've watched SNL my whole life and I
will no longer be watching because his
racist now and I think to myself you
better look at the cast if you've been
watching it your whole life you've
probably already seen some racism you
know you probably you know it's like
that show has been white for a long time
not to say that that's BIG's a racist
but it's like what are you looking for
right now like what are you like you're
looking at the show and being like oh
now that you some guy not on the show
yet talked about some [ __ ] off-screen in
his own
you know his own private thing and now
that makes the whole show racist when
you've been watching the show that has
been predominantly white for 40 years
okay there's always just one black guy
you know a few women and just recently
they've tried to change that and you
didn't you didn't see a problem with all
that before your whole life but now this
is like this is the culture in right now
this is kind of shocking all you know
shocking aw we're gonna get up cancel um
and then move the [ __ ] on column so I
just I'm not with it at the same time I
do understand it though like I
understand I'm okay with people but I'm
gonna say again I'm okay with people
being sensitive I'm okay with people
voicing their sensitivity I'm just not
okay with how we're going about dealing
with it afterwards you know it should be
just be like what like again with
Chappelle special people have a thought
this is their thought about it and then
after that it's just like okay you spoke
your piece now let's move on let it go
you know what I mean all right I want to
go to some of the question-and-answer
section of zip outgassed
people have asked a lot of really
interesting questions so let's go to
some of them all right this is from on
Instagram I'm not gonna read people's
freaking handles cuz you guys are all
stupid with your dumb handles
everybody's handle should be their name
you know what I mean and maybe there's
zip code or like you know if they give
ya like if there's another Eric Griffin
it should be like err Griffin la Eric
Griffin Boston or Eric Griffin I know
zero zero what you know whatever it is
but these dumbass names stupid anyway it
seems that you prefer Xbox / ps4 am I
wrong no I do prefer Xbox because I like
to controller the Xbox controller is
just [ __ ] banner okay it's big I got
big hands do you still use Liverpool
Football when you play cut with FIFA ha
that's the old school question from
somebody I used to play fifa with no I
you know what I stopped following the
teams so I just kind of look at the
stats and whatever stats I like I pick
that team actually been like like in the
most German team the yellow the with the
yellow uniforms I forgot to Germany with
the I usually play with them you guys
figure it out in the comments what's
your personal occupational ambitions
you'd be a great Bond villain ha you
know what I would love to be like a
villain in something you know just be
the bad guy play against my like you
know a happy guy personality type you
know mitt like Robin Williams did that's
what I compare myself to Robin Williams
I'm just saying it was great that he was
such a happy guy and everything and then
then he started to really be great at
being a villain or just a serious and
from doing I'm down up here I'm really
ready to do more serious roles so but my
personal occupational goals is just to
be able to continue to work just
continue to work and also get to the
point where I'm working because I want
to not because I have to what is the
purpose of a mustache you know I really
don't know I don't know there must be
some sort of scientific reason why the
body has a mustache I just don't know
what it is I think it's like it maybe
you're supposed to catch snot maybe it's
a snot catcher or you know to keep like
good particles out of your mouth or or
from going in you like when you sniff up
maybe it's like dirt is supposed to
catch in your mustache before it goes
into your nose or something I don't know
what the purpose of a mustache but I
know some of the things I do dirty if
you produce a movie what would it be I
don't know I just you know what I want
to get back to making fun rum like fun
rated R comedies you know what I mean
where there's titties and and people are
laughing at stuff and we can still have
strong female characters and have
titties you know what I mean it's okay
let's just do everything tastefully
funny and tasteful rated are fun
comedies we're gonna get back to that
you know what I mean um what are you
gonna see an official scorpion lashes
podcast I don't know yet I actually just
had kalila on my podcast and we talked
about it so we'll see what happens we'll
see what the future brings man okay
let's go to the next page thoughts on
the Joker and a future talk of Jonah
Hill as a penguin
yeah Jonah Hill is a great actor you
know I mean I
I don't have any problem with him being
that if Danny DeVito can do it Jonah
Hill can do it and the Joker just looks
dark and you know interesting and like
this what I'm saying rated-r I I can't
wait for like what an interesting
character that has been in our minds for
so long Joker and Batman so I just can't
wait to see what that looks like it
should be a good one how did you get
into comedy and how do you come up with
a material well I got into comedy by
starting to go to open mikes by myself
and just staying in the circuit and just
building a reputation and just keep
writing and writing and writing and
writing and writing and I come up with
material because I'm very whatever's
going on in my life or whatever I
observe I like to think about what my
take is on that and then put it on put
it on stage you know that's how I do it
let me see here oh how funny are you
compared to how funny you think you are
ah
that is a great [ __ ] question how
funny are you compared to how funny you
think you are
damn why you making me really go
introspective on this [ __ ] like I don't
know you know I can only look at the
crowds like what when I'll say this
about myself when I'm on when I'm in the
pocket and my rhythm I'm on stage and
like I could see people really enjoying
me like crying and belly laughing so
sometimes I think I'm really really
funny but I sometimes though I know I'm
not as smart as I think I am I think I'm
as funny as I think I am but I don't
think I'm as smart as I think I am but
actually excellent question um yeah
somebody asked me that twice I like that
let me see what was the first joke you
ever wrote oh the first joke I ever
wrote was about having a big nose so
like it was I don't know I can't do it
in this chair actually I think I could
do it in this chair so I would be like
this is the first joke I ever wrote okay
first joke ever so you people that are
listening I'll describe it but your
people are watching you'll get it more
closely closely but I'd be like I have a
big nose and when you have a big nose
you only taking pictures one way just
like this people say turn to the side
so people that are listening what I
would do is I would keep my head
straight and turn my body to the right
or left you know it's just to say you
know I'm always in pro I'm never in a
profile shot anyway I don't know you
probably probably listens it doesn't
sound as funny it probably looks but you
should be really funny tells the first
joke I wrote I love that joke let's see
a bomb what are your top five video
games my top five video games are
Destiny's number one destiny because
I've been playing it for five six years
any game you could play that long and
then FIFA is number two and I just count
um all the diversions is the same just
playing that sports game is pretty fun I
really enjoy that those two what's
another good game infamous on ps4 that
was a really great game to play I really
enjoyed that game and Batman Batman
Arkham Knight oh man that game is so fun
the fighting - you really feel what
you're doing with the fighting I love
that game so that's best driving music I
think the best driving music is whatever
mood you're in you know what I mean like
sometimes sometimes like sometimes I'm
an easy listening move or sometimes I'm
in like a jazz mood so jazz is a really
good driving music country music is
great when you're driving because just
hearing those stories and they're in
there like on a current road you know I
mean I just love country music that's a
great one - alright here we go
experiences differences in other
countries yeah I think that the
differences in other countries a lot of
a lot of cultural things you know like
when you go to Europe you know it just
feels older it feels like it has a way
older history than the United States and
saying you could see it in the buildings
and the culture and like you know it's
like when you go someplace in New York
and it's like here's a deli
I'll just tell he's been here since 1925
you know you go to Europe and some [ __ ]
has been there since 1725 or something
here's an old church so I just feel like
the culture in other countries it's like
sometimes it's just more old and rich
and you know in the obviously the food
is always different in different places
you look a fat guy talk about our food
um let's see your your review of 90 day
fiancé
listen there's so many different shells
of 90 day fiancé not Eve 90 day fiancé
is if that show infuriates me you know
it's just crazy people thinking like you
know what there's two kinds of couples
online ad a fiancee you got you got the
the cute you get the hot couple these
are two people but there's still
something going on because one of them
is just trying to get a green card and
in this quirky relationship but you kind
of feel like it can work or there's one
worse like some old guy some fat guy or
some fat girl or some old fat girl that
you know that's just a show watch it the
in error and they're in love with some
young in shape good guy or girl and you
know who's trying to get their green
card and it's just exploitative I just
sometimes I hate that for the show but I
can't stop watching it if today's
comedians can make it can't wait the I
guess the question is can today's
comedians make it without a podcast
slash social media can they make it yeah
I think so I thought you still need
something you know like are you saying
like if it was just TV or yeah III don't
know I think you're gonna need something
so actually I don't know if a comedian
today can start and not have social
media and make it happen cuz these clubs
are out here like what's your social
media numbers like you know you know
that that's all they [ __ ] care about
right now social media all right the
first time you ever experienced
wonder open-world videogames and it
blows you away oh I guess that was you
know infamous was the first open-world
video game on ps4 that I was like oh wow
this is incredible you could just go
anywhere you want to go which is pretty
dope I also like Gears of War on Xbox by
the way oh let's see favorite childhood
story damn I don't know if I have a
favorite childhood toy but what's coming
to mind right now is I used to be this
restaurant called carnation it was you
know by the carnation company was like a
little day a little deli like a little
cafe like but like Danny's style foo
like House of pancake but they always
had the best ice cream sundaes and I
remember I'm going there with my mom and
like I was a young kid and I was like my
I want to get a sundae and she was like
no you're not gonna get like a shake it
was a shake and she was like no you're
not gonna get it we're gonna share it
you know and then she drank most of it
I'll never forget that it was the first
time I was like damn I'm out selfish
with food probably why I'm selfish with
food but she drank the whole [ __ ]
shake y'all left me like this much and I
was like yo what's going on and then she
was like started laughing she's a
oh my god it was like so good as she
forgot you supposed to share with her
son damn it let's see where we got here
when did you first
when did your first television
experience experience did you like it
and if you feel it brought you up
brought up and you brought you up in
your career that's a weird question I'm
just I'm just a terrible reader a
workaholics was my really my first first
major thing so as you know workaholics
is like the reason why I'm here today
so workaholics is dope it's a great
experience and I'll always treasure the
you know the Montez love somebody
already asked I would love to hear your
talk about this season's big brother and
your opinions on it yeah I already
that's the first thing I started with
y'all so you got to go look go back and
look at that [ __ ] here's a question it
just says Theo von I guess I'm just
supposed to talk about deal I love Theo
he just like the you know when you watch
him it's just like it's like it's almost
like I wish I could see the cartoon like
above his head of like the things that
he's saying you know what I mean he's
just like an interesting cat and I'm
glad that things are working out for him
right now he's a real good dude and he
deserves it Oh thoughts on Call of Duty
I'll still love Call of Duty I just I
haven't won yet you know what I mean God
my candle guy just asked me if I want
more do you want more candles for your
studio yeah when he's run out you gonna
send me some more candles [ __ ] I
want some more those damn candles Pelosi
is announcing inquiring into impeachment
damn I'm so 50/50 on this impeachment
thing because I feel like he should be
voted out are you gonna make him a
martyr but at the same time I feel like
even if he if he goes out of office he's
still gonna be a thorn in our side he's
gonna like puppy be on fox news or
something like that oh they'll have the
Trump report you know the hope he'll
he'll find a way to get on TV and still
be even more famous and then he has car
blanche to do whatever business that he
wants but this might be the smoking gun
for him but I don't know they keep
saying this but this guy keeps surviving
I think Nancy Pelosi did not want to do
this she was adamant about it I think I
think she saw even before the Muller
report she was talking about like let's
not worry about impeachment let's just
vote him out
I think she saw MA Loretta at a
Starbucks and he was like and then you
know what I mean
so but I don't know I just wish my
problem with Muller I wish he was just
[ __ ] say something just say I think
something happened you know she's being
so wishy-washy so if he like just say
straight out what you think man
just tell us you think the dudes a crook
just say that or say I don't think he
did anything illegal but there can't
what's all this wishy-washy middle
ground stuff man just say something dude
how about people in the industry that
shut you down without names of course
who shut yeah I've had managers and
agents who have like you know done some
fucked-up things but yet you say no
names I'm not gonna even go into that
right now
talk about why you don't come to
Columbus Ohio I have come to hold
Columbus Ohio but that particular Club
is it's a tough sell and like that Club
the president runs that Club you know he
wants you to like you have to like he
doesn't he doesn't care about growth
he's not he's not trying to grow your
audience he wants you to already have an
audience so it's that kind of thing so
maybe if you know you know all you
people out in Columbus Ohio if you
really want me to come to Columbus let's
start banging the drum you know let's
start calling the club being like yeah I
need I want Eric Griffin that goes for
anybody out there any state any city you
want me to come I want to come but these
clubs gotta know that people want me to
come so get your ass out there and bang
the drum all right what makes a comedy
club great the staff the layout or the
crowd great question this is a great
question what makes a comedy club great
for me it's never about the crowd I want
well it has to have a good sound it has
a good sound system and good lighting
can they see me can they hear me that
should be the basics okay but for me I
never necessarily worry about the crowd
I'm worried about the hotel like where
am I staying is there a movie theater
nearby is there stuff to do am I gonna
be sequestered the other 22 hours of the
day so that's what to me makes a good
comedy club but you know but for you
fans it's like it's long as it's a good
setup can everybody see the comedian and
can everybody hear the comedian those
are the most important things
just [ __ ] on Bobby and Santino for an
hour that'll be a whole other podcast
like [ __ ] dumbass little Bobby and a
red [ __ ] you're gonna mean trying to cut
me out of it you know we're gonna do
puckers you know no they're not but I'm
not you know what I want to officially
say even on my podcast if they want to
do a podcast you totally have my
blessing I love them both they are my
friends but I am gonna go on there and
I'm gonna [ __ ] sabotage while I'm on
there what's the most embarrassing
moment of your life oh man I have so
many of the hoes but one embarrassing
well was like this is such a common one
for people but you know I was like in
the fifth grade and like you know I had
sweats on and then you know I had to you
have to read in front of the you know
Eric come up and read it and I had a
hard-on you know I mean I my dick was
like you know and everybody was noticed
it was laughing and I was like I just
kept reading it I was like I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna acknowledge this just keep
going you know I mean somebody said talk
about Bobby Lee I already did I love
Bobby you know if I want to talk about
Bob Bobby's a little weird [ __ ] but he's
one of my best friends in the whole wide
world it's you know I'm I love that do
for life unless he [ __ ] up you know I
mean what are you doing another show in
Florida I don't know I'm working on it
again you want me to come to Florida
call the club you want me to come to
tweet at the club Instagram the club but
if you literally call the club that's
even better like if you phone call you
know I know I know you guys don't like
you Millennials don't like talking on
the phone and you don't even understand
how that works
call them and be like yo can you bring
Eric Irfan to the comedy club I think
that does a lot more man you'd be
surprised
would you rather do a podcast with Bobby
Lee or Andrew Santino damn I think
they're those elves would be both great
if I'm gonna have
I haven't had Andrew on Griffin with
Griffin yet but I might have him on but
I don't know I think that that would be
both I've had to pick if I had to pick
I'd probably pick Bobby just cuz him and
I have a thing that is like it's just
crazy when we get together talk about
turning 50 [ __ ] you that's what I'll say
there to that
so couple use a few years away bro
alright but I don't know I did I don't
know if I've accomplished all that I've
wanted to accomplish professionally
personally so I got to I didn't I didn't
I didn't know what I was gonna be doing
at this time in my life I love what I'm
doing right now but at the same time I'm
like damn this is I still feel like
there's unknown out there and so we'll
see what happens when I you know cruise
into 50 let's see no greatest comedy duo
in your opinion greatest comedy duo I
don't know there's so many of them maybe
you know Jerry Lewis and Dean and Dean
Martin or Bob Hope and Dean Martin you
know key and Peele you know can you peel
their [ __ ] funny ass duo mustache
maintenance tips damn this is a good one
too well you know what
I got you got manscaped you know you
should get manscape they got some good
products there but that's more for your
balls but they still got good products
you don't have to use that trimmer for
your balls but you know you know you
want to make sure your moustache doesn't
go on your lip that's a hard thing to do
so my moustache grow so fast so you want
to trim the lip you know you want to
make sure it's not too fluffy you want
to get a comb keep it combed out and if
you have some like sort of like
conditioner for your mustache that's
also good too to keep it nice and soft
you know when you're kissing the ladies
or or they're whoever you're kissing
whatever your thing is you know what I
mean and when you're doing other things
with your mouth you want your money you
know what you must best be to course you
want it to be soft and luxurious a lot
of the questions about shit-talking
Bobby which is so weird
star wars rankings damn that's a good
one
star wars rankings oh [ __ ] what if I
just say the worst star wars movie is
the the one thus if one where Anakin
Skywalker goes crazy and starts but
right before he turns into Darth Vader
which I think that was like rise of the
Sith that one was terrible all those
were actually terrible those are like
the worst three right there along with
Dan they're all some of them are so bad
I think [ __ ] those ones about I can't
remember all the bad ones but I would
say that the original three are my
favorite I'm not returning the Jedi guy
sorry for you pretentious Empire Strikes
Back people but for me is Jedi Empire
than the original Star Wars and then
rogue one
I thought rogue one was pretty good that
was a that was a really good Star Wars
movie
please get blind Kalinin soon okay I
could do that you know alright that's
pretty good there's more Instagram
questions but I'm not gonna go into them
you know let me do it there's actually
some good Twitter questions too so let
me go to Twitter right now and grab
those and grab those Twitter questions
and once again guys I really want to
thank you guys for supporting wherefrom
with Griffin and you know just watching
you know and all the stuff that you've
been doing okay
see if was there any good Twitter
questions you've had some great casts
wouldn't be mad at a best-of oh yeah
maybe a best-of episode you know you
know what you're right actually I didn't
even get any quitter Twitter questions
best comic gamer you've played with
that's Bobby Bobby leaves my best comic
gamer I know I should come out with like
a best of of what Griffon maybe like
even maybe even right now we cut to a
montage of all my favorite episodes so
you know we cap in 50 episodes of RIF
and what Griffin it's been a fantastic
run I really had a fun time doing this
and you know episode 52 will be a year
so that's gonna be another one another
special one but I just wanted to say
thank you to the fans and people
listening you know all the [ __ ] that I
talk on this damn thing and all the
people that come on the podcast you know
I have these really interesting
conversations with people and I got a
really interesting one coming up I got
this nerd coming on Dylan Dixon
Dickstein
Dylan Dickstein I know weird name do you
want he's gonna be an astronaut I met
him on the Logan Paul podcast he was
just you know he was just there and he's
such a fascinating kid he talks about
Mars and he talks about going to Mars
and space and it's just I just wanted to
have somebody that's outside the
entertainment business to come on and
just see how that goes too so make sure
you guys keep watching we're from with
Griffin I really appreciate it
I love I love all the fans I love all
the fans I love all the support you know
what let's go let's let's get some let's
get some rhythm with Griffin themes
there's some theme music going on right
here where we got where the music at
we're just riffing with Griffin theme
songs at y'all
all these theme songs that people sent
to me I love them you know especially
detective designs you know these are my
guys so ladies and gentlemen thank you
for listening to riffing with Griffin
like I said I love y'all on the singing
mic but what my question to you is why
didn't you brush before like know me
because but knowing you have a mouth in
American society
I use crest whitening whatever the best
I do swear to god you do twice a day
once in the morning yeah in the shower
and then at night okay all right so let
me get this straight you came prepared
with a moustache truth be told I always
you had a moustache ready to go yeah I
use a moustache in my act so you never
know when you remember that now actually
net you know what I'm not as mad about
it now put your heart and soul into your
visit I'd like to do it again and I have
the glass no that's like yeah we've miss
me off
a micro that I work with they're all
just pig monsters they anything
I mean Jeremiah and red ban and Joel are
human garbage disposals without it I
don't know how Jeremiah does it like
where does he put it it's just all in
his nose the last date that I went on I
fell asleep
damn what whoa okay whoa why was it
because it was too late at night no
first of all this is not watching at
home this ain't real brick I don't even
know where you get this at some party
shop and [ __ ] Tijuana yeah what is
this it's exactly what you think it is
it's a it's a piece of paper with a
brick wall on yeah it looks nice though
that's what I'm saying when I look at it
on camera yeah what I like is how people
are still finding it people are finding
it like it's like it's new or something
I'm starting to like I've been noticing
like in Twitter mentions people going
back and watching it again yeah oh yeah
it's like getting to be that time where
it's like well even me I was like over
at Adams talking to him and we were
trying that we're just going through
like episodes just be like like which
some were like stompers why do I always
go to the but anyway see y'all
[Music]